one last chance to relax together before
things start to get uncomfortable an
appointment with dr. Roberts
is not something these penguins seem to
be looking forward to so at the moment
what we're doing is we're just checking
on the Penguins and making sure that
they're all ready for release so each
one has his own penguin card this is
medical record this one
he had an oil spill so he was 70% oiled
and he was emaciated he was really
underweight the conservationists take in
seabirds in peril and try to prepare
them to be released back into the wild
thousands of injured animals come here
every year some will stay here forever
as they would not survive in their
natural habitats but these birds might
not be here in the long term they are in
danger of extinction it's quite possible
that anyone can go extinct in the future
and we've had dramatic declines in
penguin numbers even between the counts
from last year and this year the numbers
have dropped by about 7 mm reading pairs
so we have less than 20,000 reading
pairs that scarily know these penguins
first have to spend time in a small box
but only briefly until they have fully
recovered and are ready to return to the
wilderness in simon's town one of the
few remaining penguin colonies they are
released
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it went really well that was really nice
to be able to see them go out so quickly
they didn't get confused the crowd was
very polite and not too noisy
so that didn't scare the Penguins and
they they went straight out in the
direction they should have gone and
really we can't see them I think there's
one head sticking out over there so now
the threats that they face are the same
as all the other wild penguins people
need to think about the impacts of what
they're doing and how they can affect
not only the Penguins but all other sea
life and other wildlife that is in
danger from human interaction still the
message seems to have got through to the
hundreds of people in the crowd over
here we have a lot of organizations who
are trying to save the oceans and the
animals and and obviously the Penguins
were being rehabilitated and then put
back in but there's a lot more we can do
yes we must do more to protect them
because you see what is happening at sea
this is not only clean as it used to be
there's plastic problem however the
biggest threat to the African penguin is
the lack of fish they are not enough
anchovies and sardines in the oceans due
to overfishing in the worst case
scenario the last African penguin colony
will die out in 20 or 30 years but
people here definitely want to prevent
that from happening